un film pour mieux comprendre leur
parcours un film pour mieux expliquer la
réalité d'une société en perdition mais
qui ne perd pourtant pas espoir
la septième promotion de l' académie des
dalons du bernica semic devant et
derrière la caméra pour réaliser le film
dalo un court métrage qui sur un ton
humoristique retrace le parcours d'une
bande de jeunes qui se laisse vivre mais
qui est vite rattrapé par la violence du
milieu dans lequel ils ont choisi
d'évoluer pour en tant qu' après spa du
café le rôle du gros bras à la fin de
mois je vais avec la met l'argent que
les autres personnages doivent était
dans le comité saint arnaud et on s'est
tu quand d'autres on a donné un peu la
main on attendait un peu
aj le rôle du dernier arrêt voilà j'ai
pris ça à coeur c'est au casino du port
que famille ballon et toute l'équipe de
l'académie se sont retrouvés pour
visionner ce projet collectif commun à
toutes les promotions
ici c'est l'image et l'imagination d'un
scénario écrit et tourné en toute
liberté qui reprend la notion de travail
en commun
jammes envoie des responsabilités ce
projet-là janvier
j'ai fait partie du comité scénario donc
voilà j'ai écrit les scénarios avec eux
plusieurs personnes on a donné nos idées
on a mélangé
les idées on essaie de trouver les
meilleures idées
c'est difficile quand on fait un film à
plusieurs car il faut prendre et l'idée
de tout le monde on était 15
il fallait prendre l'idée tout le monde
en comptait c'était vraiment difficile à
trancher mais on s'est vite mis d'accord
des parcours différents difficile qui
depuis quelques mois se sont transformés
de nouveaux congés des académies des
dalons leur apporter beaucoup ils ont de
nouveau envie de croire on leur dit ce
temps me de reprendre confiance en moi c
est plusieurs à tv qui m'ont beaucoup
aidé et j'ai eu la chance de de faire
partie de l'aventuré
je peux appeler ça une aventure oui
c'était une chance pour moi
personnellement poma ça ça me fait rire
parce que j'arrive à me reconstruire
mais aussi à me poser positivement bin
haji hassan aujourd'hui me sens mieux
cadrer et mis aussi sur mes appuis un
moment j'avais pu vraiment confiance en
moi et je me suis dit ben pourquoi pas
vraiment quand je suis entré à
l'académie d'alger mme simard là c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment là que je
pourrais travailler mon ma confiance en
soi et voilà on maîtrise de soi parce
que c'était quelqu'un d'assez
impulsif aussi avoir une posture
professionnelle
ça m'a changé avis c'était par camélia
et ça nous apporte beaucoup de choses
je remercie academy dalons et monsieur
karmique cinq ans au qui met pas l'école
déjà et vous avez quand même pas mal de
petits problèmes à l'école
depuis qu'il est rentré à l'académie des
dalons comme je vous dis bien et laissez
a lieu il fait son travail correctement
il arrive à la maison il déballe son
linge il fait sa machine avant c'était
pas le cas du tout ce sont néanmoins
bien rangée lâchant bien manger ce court
métrage de fiction qui reflète néanmoins
très bien un pan de la société dans
laquelle on vit dans laquelle vivent ces
jeunes se veut avant tout être en
support pour permettre à d'autres jeunes
de mieux comprendre leurs difficultés
mais surtout de me comprendre que des
solutions existent
cette convention la a décidé de partir
sur la réalisation d'un film avec entre
en travaillant sont des questions un peu
plus contemporaine donc laissez
travailler à partir d'une histoire
qu'ils ont monté un scénario et sur des
sujets qui le questionnait et dans
lesquelles ils pouvaient être pour
certains directement concernés donc
c'est un film relativement engagé par
rapport à tout ce qu'on a pu faire
après ce travail collectif les garçons
de la promotion où chaque accomplir leur
service civique dans les domaines qui
leur tiennent à coeur
ils ont chacun des envies des rêves
grâce à la confiance qu'ils ont retrouvé
à l'académie ils sont prêts à franchir
tous les obstacles pour réussir leur vie